they know you're against credit cards
and debt
my question is how are we supposed to
build credit with no credit cards Andre
says on Twitter well you're not what I'm
not well why would you build credit what
do you need credit for so you can borrow
money why you borrow money so I can
build my credit why are you building
your credit so I can borrow money why my
borrowing money so I can build my credit
it's a dog chasing its tail people spend
their whole lives doing this stupid
exercise of worshipping at the altar of
the great FICO you are the first
generation listening to me right now
that believes that FICO is necessary to
have a quality life everyone else used
to think money would do it getting out
of debt and having savings having
investments having a net worth and
having an income these are actual
measures of financial prowess actual
measures of financial success the FICO
score is not an indication that you're
good with money it's an indication
you've paid a lot of debt payments on
time that just means you're stupid this
is the Dave Ramsey show